I feel like it's sort of Groundhog Day
but once again the current government
and administration is going out of its
way to ease sanctions on a company tied
to none other than Russian oligarch Oleg
Deripaska who if his name sounds
familiar to you you might recall is an
increasingly common name in Robert
Morris from Prussia investigation at
this point and the Russian aluminum
company in question is called ruse all
our usal it was sanctioned earlier this
month why because of allegations that
they were involved in all sorts of
illegal activities including money
laundering extortion and even ordering a
murder that firm is tied to Oleg
Deripaska he's a Russian oligarch who's
tied to Vladimir Putin he's part of
Robert Moeller's investigation into
Trump Russia collusion he's the guy that
was reportedly getting private briefings
from Trump campaign manager Paul
Manafort who's now been indicted of
course about the 2016 election even as
close as two weeks to the 2016 election
this was a decision made by the Treasury
Department and what it will do is extend
by six months a sort of wind down period
during which American and foreign
entities can keep doing business with
rasol without being penalized and the
Office of Foreign Assets Control is
reportedly considering lifting sanctions
altogether on ruse all now of course it
might just be the optics that are
atrocious here but why would Trump's
Treasury Department run by of course
Trump's elections Stephen minuchin why
would they want to relieve sanctions on
this one firm that just happens to be
Trump connected and it just happens to
be connected to Russian oligarch Oleg
Deripaska who in his own right is
connected to Donald Trump nothing to see
here just pure coincidence again in this
long and quite frankly unbelievable
string of coincidences very very
difficult to believe and something like
this happens and all of a sudden I sound
like one of those US Treasury conspiracy
theorists yelling about how there's no
oversight on the Treasury they can do
whatever they want what happened to
checks and balances and
then I remember oh right the people
meant to check and balance the Treasury
are in the middle of the entire scandal
it's the Trump Whitehouse that could try
to balance out or check the Treasury
it's the republican-controlled house and
the republican-controlled Senate that
could conceivably check and balance the
Treasury they're not gonna do it no
one's gonna do it and instead we are de
facto easing sanctions on the people
were supposed to be targeting with the
sanctions and it all goes back to hyper
normalization the hyper normalization
that we're experiencing is beyond belief
by and large we're standing by powerless
while a foreign power continues to use
their leverage on our President to get
whatever it is that they want to sow
discord and chaos and this is exactly
how a compromised administration would
behave so I guess nikki Haley this
happened during our break nikki Haley
really was maybe confused during our
vacation where she said it's more
sanctions that are coming against Russia
and Russian entities and in fact were
removing sanctions against Russian
entities and in the end they're doing
this so openly because they think they
can get away with it because they
probably can they probably will get away
with it and that's actually the most
disturbing part because there's lots of
people who just don't want to believe
any of this stuff is concerning right
you've got the committed Trumpets who
just don't concede that anything unusual
is going on
you've got elements of the left that are
very disturbingly pretending or claiming
or believing they've been convinced
arguably that nothing is going on with
Russia and more than likely nothing will
actually come of this stuff we'll see
what happens with Moeller's
investigation but they are gonna get
away with this stuff and that is
actually going to be used as evidence to
say hey listen if there was actually
something untoward happening then they
wouldn't have gotten away with it with
this which is completely circular
reasoning what will we learn tomorrow I
don't know we'll wait and see
send me your thoughts you can discuss
this on our reddit discussion forum at
david pakman.com slash our IDI di t we
will take a break and be back next with
stephen bonell now
to many in our online audience as
destiny today's episode of the program
is made possible in part by coin
schedule which is a listing site for
cryptocurrency icos that's been around
since 2016 and was actually one of the
first websites to show helpful listing
information about icos where you can
look them up by name by industry by
start and end date and you'll get from
coin schedule a score for each IC o----
that can help you better assess how
careful you should be if you are looking
at investing in any particular IC o----
coin schedule like me says that they
hate scams and one of the guys from coin
schedule was actually telling me about
how they do everything they can to weed
out the scam IC o---- so that they
straight-up don't appear on their
website and it seems that they've
learned a lot from doing this over the
past two years coin schedule is also a
really good resource for finding
information about upcoming
cryptocurrency related conferences they
also post crypto news and if you're
watching this on youtube i've put a link
to the coin schedule website at the top
of the description to be clear nothing
on coin schedule should be considered
personalized investment advice icos are
risky everybody should do their own
research and make the decisions that are
right for them